if you're a reborn Christian and you say
well I don't have
self-control then in a sense you're
right because we all have that sinful
fleshly nature within us and it's going
to be there until the day we die and it
pushes us to do sin like overeating gony
getting angry and quarrel or not study
but be lazy it is that fleshly nature
within you that brings you
down but you see if you are a true
reborn Christian you have received a new
spiritual nature God himself the Holy
Spirit came and live inside of you you
see there is a change and now you can
choose to live through the spirit and
the spirit can overcome the Flesh and it
is the only Power that can overcome the
sinful nature